je ne sais pas comment france ni en
russe mais en tout cas sont des paroles
que l'on pourrait bien attribué aux deux
cosmonautes soviétiques vladimir yaakov
et valérie aux mines qui ont attiré
aujourd'hui après dix ans 75 jours
passés à tourner autour de la terre ce
qui constitue le record du monde des
vols habités depuis le début des vols
spatiaux
un long voyage qui préfigure la future
mes proches conquête de l'espace
un exploit qui pourtant a bien failli
tourner à la catastrophe dans les
cosmonautes ont eu de problème avec
l'arrimage ou le désarrimage de
certaines capsules venus les rejoindre
yaakov perry yumin ont cependant
effectué un nombre d'expériences
considérable ils ont pu constater ainsi
que les plans n'arrivait jamais à
maturité en état d'apesanteur
cette étape pourrait par contre être
utile dans les expériences qui ont été
faites sur la croissance de cristaux ou
la création de nouveaux matériaux pour
celui conducteur certaines de ces
expériences ont d'ailleurs été fait en
collaboration avec les scientifiques
français mais il faut attendre
maintenant les résultats
nos deux groupes sont donc restés seuls
qu'on en crée de six mois et malgré une
liaison permanente avec la terre le
temps a dû paraître long le vaisseau
soyouz 32 qu'ils avaient amené à la
station saliou ciss a été remplacé par
le vaisseau soyouz 34 pour les ramener
sur terre
panne ou vieillesse de l'engin on ne
sera jamais quoi qu'il en soit les
exercices qu'il est effectué chaque jour
pour leur part dont leur a permis selon
l'agent stage de rentrée en pleine forme
mais à leur arrivée les deux héros ont
reçu le titre jusqu'aux le monde- héros
de l'union soviétique ce qui est la plus
grande décoration soviétique également
la médaille de l'étoile d'or c'est bien
qu'on leur devait en iran l'ayatollah
khomeini interdit tous les partis
d'opposition mobilise l'armée contre les
rebelles kurdes ont dit que l'histoire
ne se répète pas mais par certains côtés
on se croirait bel et bien revenue au
mois de janvier dernier souvenez-vous le
shah d'iran s'acharnait encore à donner
des ordres qui ne se concrétisaient plus
dans les faits c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour le kurdistan ou malienne tous ces
efforts l'ayatollah commune ne peut
empêcher que la révolte s'étend 4
millions de kurdes d'iran prenne
aujourd'hui les armes contre la
république islamique de l'ayatollah
khomeini leur but
l'autonomie et la chute du pouvoir
religieux mais aujourd'hui ils veulent
surtout venger leurs onze camarades
exécutés ce matin par les gardiens de la
révolution
après les émeutes de pavés et empêcher
l'armée iranienne de contrôler leur
région à l'interdiction du parti
démocratique kurde e par l'ayatollah
khomeiny les peshmergas les combattants
kurdes ont répondu en occupant
militairement la ville de sanandaj le
chef de leur province pour leur empêcher
toute retraite en irak ou en turquie
l'ayatollah khomeiny a ordonné la
fermeture des frontières de l'iran mais
dans leurs montagnes les pechmergas sont
comme des poissons dans l'eau et peuvent
mener la guérilla pendant des années
contre l'armée iranienne et les gardiens
de la révolution
aujourd'hui les kurdes ont retrouvé
leurs vieux réflexes retourner dans
leurs montagnes où ils ont caché leurs
armes et reprendre cette guerre de
résistance qu'il mène depuis 30 ans
contre les pouvoirs en place en irak en
iran ou en turquie aps
en engageant contre les pechmergas toute
l'armée iranienne et les gardiens de la
révolution en refusant l'autonomie aux
kurdes en interdisant leur parti
l'ayatollah khomeini se met à dos toutes
les minorités de l'iran les baloutche
les turkmènes les arabes du khouzistan
qui eux aussi demande d'autonomie
le problème kurde a fait tomber dans
l'histoire une bonne dizaine de
gouvernement en lançant toutes ses
forces dans la bataille contre les
pechmergas le régime islamique de
l'ayatollah khomeini pourrait bien lui
aussi s'y casser les dents
messieurs polpot et ieng sary les
anciens premiers ministres et ministres
les affaires étrangères du régime
mary chassés en janvier dernier ont été
condamnées à mort par contumace par le
nouveau régime cambodgien aujourd'hui
ils ont été reconnus coupables de
génocide
responsable de la mort de trois hommes
et deux femmes un jugement qui
apparaîtra sans doute quelque peu
dérisoire sans doute aux yeux des
cambodgiens pour qui je dirais que le
génocide se poursuit presque
naturellement puisque aujourd'hui qui
sont victimes de la famine qui s'étend à
plusieurs régions du pays
on en a la confirmation par ces
premières images qui nous parviennent du
cambodge
des images que l'on pourrait qualifier
de terribles mais à ce degré de détresse
les mots ont ils encore une
signification ils ont ce même visage que
les réfugiés du biafra les détenus des
camps les infamies du sahel
les rescapés d'une catastrophe en inde
mais ici nous sommes dans un hôpital de
phnom penh la capitale du cambodge
rongé par la famine et les équilibres la
famine parce qu'en raison de la guerre
les récoltes n'ont pu être fait
les épidémies parce que dans le cambodge
occupée il n'y a pratiquement plus de
médecin dans cet hôpital
trois médecins et quatre étudiants
soigne plus de 700 malades
sous-alimentés
le cambodge comptait autrefois 500
médecins
il n'en reste plus qu'une cinquantaine
il ne dispose même pas d'antibiotiques
les réserves de sang les vaccins les
flacons de perfusion sont épuisés depuis
longtemps la croix rouge internationale
et les nations unies ont envoyé à ses
enfants
70 de médicaments car jusque là aucune
aide ne pouvait leur parvenir une
révolution manquée une invasion
étrangère celle du vietnam
un voisin la thaïlande qui refoulent les
réfugiés de maquis khmers rouges
toujours tenaces ont fait du cambodge le
pays de la fin l'incertitude totale
pèsent sur le sort de deux millions de
ces cambodgiens qui n'ont pas réussi à
prendre le chemin de l'exode sauf le
respect que l'on doit à un président des
états unis
on pourrait dire que jimmy carter fait
n'importe quoi pour remonter la pente sa
dernière idée descendre le mississippi
sur un bateau à roue pour convaincre ses
compatriotes de lui faire à nouveau
confiance
il faut dire que chaque jour qui passe
amène une mauvaise nouvelle de plus pour
le président américain aujourd'hui par
exemple il est question d'une annulation
du sommet s'adapte begin qui devait se
tenir début septembre à haïfa en israël
la réunion pourrait avoir lieu à
washington en présence du président
carter et puis il ya bien sûr les
conséquences de l'affairé ou non
seulement la démission de l'ambassadeur
mécontente à l'extérieur les
palestiniens et les dirigeants arabes
modérés mais à l'intérieur elles ne
satisfait ni la minorité noire dont
monsieur jung était le représentant
allemand ni les juifs américains qui
n'ont plus confiance dans le président
non plus cette décision risque de monter
l'une contre l'autre les deux
communautés comme l'a constaté notre
correspondant aux états unis jacques sic
voici harlem le quartier noir à la
pointe de manhattan
un million d'habitants qui ont accueilli
dans la grogne la démission de andrew ya
déception et colère car le représentant
américain aux nations unies compenser
d'une certaine façon les rêves inachevés
des noirs américains condamnés à la rue
au chômage et à la musique au point de
cette rue de harlem
voici d'ailleurs lionel en tant que plus
grand musicien de jazz qui ne veut pas
se prononcer sur la feria
il était à la pêche pendant que tout
ceci est arrivé mais en tome va être
très vite relayée par un des leaders de
la 125e rue un militant noir qui crient
à l'injustice qui regrette départ dans
le hand et ils affirment les juifs ont
pas faire la politique des états unis
biangue est un bouc émissaire et aux
prochaines élections et noir et les
juifs on suivre chacun leur chemin
chez nous aussi nous les noirs on veut
tromper kennedy pour l'actuel
vice-président mével mais surtout pas
les animosités pourrait se transformer
en querelle dans new york où il ya 3
millions de juifs qui en 1976 avaient
voté dans leur grande majorité pour
cartes et 20 aujourd'hui ils sont
mécontents de carter des rues de rouille
ang attise la querelle entre les deux
communautés
je crains beaucoup ils deviennent un
avocat pour le pied l'eau pour les
palestiniens
et cela va rendre la tension entre les
juifs et les noix plus fort j'espère
qu'il n'y aura pas de conflit
parce que les minorités qu'elles soient
noirs ou qu'elles soient juives doivent
se défendre aux états unis mais nous
approchons les élections présidentielles
de 1981 et j'ai très peur
il y aura des candidats soient de gauche
soit excellent droite même démocrates ou
républicains qui vont exploiter cette
animosité pour obtenir des grottes
pour leur élection quant au président
carter après cette nouvelle affaire il
est le grand perdant sur toute la ligne
la communauté juive ne veulent plus de
lui comme président et les noirs sont
prêts à l'abandonner
il semble qu'une nouvelle fois carter se
trouvait prisonniers écartelé entre ces
deux personnages le président qui doit
gouverner et le candidat qui aimerait
être élue en 1980 c'est-à-dire dans un
an comme président tirant les
conséquences de ses erreurs passées
il a sanctionné andrew yang mais comme
candidat il a sans doute perdu en deux
jours des millions de suffrages
en france les incendies de forêts dans
les bouches du rhône ont finalement fait
deux morts deux sapeurs pompiers de
marseille retrouvé carbonisé dans une
calanque le point de la situation avec
jean martin
il aura suffi d'un brusque retournement
du vent d'un tourbillon soudain pour que
les flammes engloutissant nam est clair
les deux pompiers isolés de leurs unités
qui ont péri dans la calanque de morgiou
pour lutter contre le feu près de 3000
hommes une douzaine de canadair
mais le maître du terrain impitoyable
tank imprévisible c'est d'abord le vent
il soufflait avec des pointes de 100 du
kilomètre arrière et près de 3000
hectares de maquis et de garrigues ont
été effacés de la carte des fermes des
cabanes ont détruit des campeurs ont
échappé par miracle certains même par la
mer il a fallu évacuer près de 2000
personnes sur un fonds de 25 km de part
et d'autre de l'autoroute
marseille-cassis les flammes la menace
est parfois les habitations il n'y a pas
eu d'extension notable du feu cet
après-midi pour qu'un nouveau foyer
n'est à signaler une nette amélioration
doivent mais tout dépendra encore du
vent à noter encore une troisième
victime en rapport avec ces incendies un
pompiers de pont-saint-esprit dans le
gard a été tué et un autre gravement
blessé ce dimanche après midi alors
qu'il circulait en voiture pour se
rendre justement sur les lieux d'un
incendie dans le gard toujours à propos
des incendies à brégançon où il termine
ses vacances le président de la
république monsieur giscard d'estaing en
recevant les élus du var a réaffirmé sa
volonté de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
assurer la protection des forêts
méditerranéennes déclarant je cite que
les intéressés se mettre d'accord l'état
aidera à réaliser fin de citation en
bref encore en france alors que le
paquebot nord ouest france a
définitivement gagné les zones de la
haute mer monsieur duroméa le maire
communiste du havre accuse une nouvelle
fois le gouvernement d'avoir refusé de
subventionner les chantiers du havre
pour leur permettre d'effectuer les
travaux de réaménagement du mato
préférant payer le chômage c'est ce que
dit monsieur dur mais une nouvelle loi
d'orientation agricole est indispensable
c'est ce qu'a dit aujourd'hui monsieur
chirac qui parlait encore elle estimant
que le projet gouvernemental qui sera
présenté à l'automne est insuffisant le
19 août 1945 44,35 résistants des
étudiants presque des enfants ont été
fusillés par les nazis
à la cascade du bois de boulogne ce
matin comme chaque année une cérémonie a
eu lieu à la mémoire de ces patriotes
qui moururent sans voir leur pays et
leur vie libérés puisque ce n'est que le
le général leclerc fit son entrée à
paris à ce propos d'ailleurs antenne 2
diffusera lundi et mardi dans le cadre
de dossiers du clan de l'écran le film
de rené clément paris brûle-t-il
dans l'actualité comme dans la vie le
drame et le rire saupin et se succèdent
c'est comme il ya 50 ans mais c'est un
personnage qui depuis n'a jamais vieilli
une petite souris aux grandes oreilles
tout rond si vous n'avez pas encore
trouvé
je voudrais seulement que son museau se
termine par une truffe noire et qu'il
est affublé le plus souvent d'une
culotte rouge des plus voyants
il s'agit vous l'avez reconnu de mickey
tel qu'il fut créé par walt disney il y
a donc tout juste 50 ans
du tout bon
il ya une surprise
je
ça n'aura pas d'idée house ensemble et
pas très tranquille
le succès de mickey de tous les autres
personnages qui l'entourent est telle
qu'il constitue un monde à part un monde
de rêve que walt disney a reconstitué
grandeur nature en californie en floride
à dysney world que denise bauer pendant
cet été a parcouru les états unis pour
les téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 a
découvert vous allez le voir en
compagnie de valérie une petite
française de dix ans une star à rendre
jalouse des actrices comme garbo ou
bardot une vedette dont le nom se
retrouve dans l'encyclopedia britannica
près de celui d'albert einstein
enfin une vedette que viennent visiter
tous les ans 14 millions de touristes
son nom mickey sa résidence officielle à
près de onze mille hectares situé au
coeur de la floride cet été valérie
passer ses vacances
kraton facile
walo auxerre pourrait que pour les
personnages de walt disney le trophée
fair
vous avez nous tenons chat
la main
pour moi je pouvais la revue de [ __ ]
reste à retrouver la même ambiance que
dans les films le web de la 3d les
départs sont lâches plus vivant
je suis tout aller lâche de mickey toi
parce que non tu le disais dans sa 21e
année
c'était il ya vu
les personnages et coucy
merci et la région il a le plus frappé
du mans c'est surtout la russie
on est plus belle et plus beaux costumes
et
la jolie
faux
moi même
ma
quittons le monde merveilleux de walt
disney pour tomorrowland le monde du vin
des miens
dis-moi pas l'avis de ceux que tu as vu
qu'est ce qui t'a plu le plus à disney
world
ce qui m'a plu tout le moderne aussi
tout ce qui est moderne tout ce qui est
traditionnel de walt disney ceux qui
connaissaient déjà
oui ça m'a plu parce que c'est les mêmes
mes yeux c'est prodigieux et l'entente
si vous voulez venir à disney world
je ne connaissais pas avant
paris
l'émerveillement pour les enfants pour
les interrupteurs
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
la série de mickey voyager tranquille la
perfection je suis toujours émerveillé
quand il votre a cure
en octobre 1979 disneyworld fêtera son
100 millionième visiteur merci monsieur
walt disney d'avoir fait 100 millions
d'heureux ce qu'il ya dans nuit avec les
rêves c'est qu'on finit toujours par se
réveiller exemple avec le tiercé
aujourd'hui qui se courait à deauville
pour gagner il fallait jouer dans
l'ordre le 3 le 4 le st les rapports
dans l'ordre diminution francs pour son
enfant dans un ordre différent 2121
francs 3,4 et 5 cérémonie traditionnelle
dans le monde des courses hier soir à
deauville les cravaches d'or a été
remise au meilleur jockey de la saison
devant un reportage de pierrette brès
qui assistait justement à cette remise
des cravaches de chaque année la soirée
du gala des courses est un des hauts
lieux de l'élégance et du bottin monde
le spectacle n'est plus sur la ligne
d'arrivée du ch en course mais dans les
salons du casino de deauville avec pour
acteurs les propriétaires les
entraîneurs et les jockeys des casaques
les plus célèbres
cette fête est consacrée à la remise des
cravaches d'or récompense des meilleurs
jockeys dresse gilbert a gagné sur 17
courses plates en se mettant dans celle
900 fois au cours de l'année 78 ce
record lui a permis d'obtenir enfin
cette fois d'âge d'or en juin ont porté
44 victoires d'obstacles année dernière
ce jockey a commencé sa carrière en
montant concours hippique la cravache
d'or symbolise pour lui une parfaite
intégration dans ce métier difficile
c'est vraiment con la palper c'est
vraiment merveilleux ces logis vers pas
pour moi c'est pareil c'est merveilleux
on n'y croyait pas mais maintenant et ça
le fait accompli c'est fantastique
laissez les cours janvier attaque est
très très mal je suis très très heureux
et très fier d'avoir été choisi pour
remettre au travail parce que je trouve
ces gens aisément sein de la ville et
courage ont préféré
de leurs données vous allez venir aux
courses maintenant sûrement
les entraîneurs étaient haussiers l'onu
à laquelle le fonds soit vous d'un
champion incontesté dans les grandes
épreuves classiques ont reçu un cheval
d'or georges peu là le plus grand maître
de l'obstacle pendant de longues années
a pas eu la force de monter sur scène il
est très malade depuis de longs mois
quand jean-pierre cassel lui a remis son
cheval d'or une émotion intense se
lisait sur son visage
nous on est content parti il ya cinq
semaines dunkerque le tour de france à
la voile vient de se terminer à mon
temps les 25 voiliers sont arrivés à bon
port
tiercé dans l'ordre sapa 1er dunkerque
2e brest 3e avant de poser
définitivement sac à terre notre
navigateur maison en régaler vous
présente son dernier rapport sur l'étape
bandol sainte-maxime le vent absent
rendez-vous des paliers du tour de
france a mis le comité de course dans
l'obligation de raccourcir le parcours
le trajet s'est donc effectuée en deux
tronçons d'abord une régate de 3000
camions et par le voilier dunkerque puni
après s'être approché de sainte-maxime
aux moddeurs nouveau départ et victoire
de pays de la loire devant morbihan et k
la ligne d'arrivée franchie les bateaux
du tour repartait de vensac maxime pour
s'exercer au spi parachute le principe
est tout simple comme un parachute
ascensionnel
plus il y a neuf ans et plus vous montez
du vent qu'il y en avait suffisamment
départ des sorties maxime pour permettre
à tous du tour de rallier de cannes pays
de la loire et les bords bihan ne bat
aux bons marcheurs dans le petit temps
le nom cette 18e étape sur les trois
quarts du parcours pourtant arrivé dans
la baie de cannes c'est le régional de
l'étape le bateau cannois qui
franchissait la ligne d'arrivée en tête
ici pour une fois la parfaite
connaissance de la côte à jouer cannes a
su trouver mieux que les autres
le petit courant d'air qui leur a permis
de l'emporter garnier de c'est arrivé à
gan de bateaux piste comme au classement
général d'ailleurs mais il faut dire à
la décharge de l'équipage ils croient
que contrairement aux autres voiliers du
tour de france ils ont eu bien du mal à
trouver le financement de leurs
bâtiments et on a conduit le bateau
d'une façon sérieuse en sécurité on n'a
pas fait d'erreurs disons de
l'implication tout le monde a eu ça en
est sa brassière dans les moments les
plus difficiles en est arrivé dernier
parce qu'on a pris des options des fois
là les équipes n'est pas toujours
capable d'assurer une navigation sur la
carte
continue moi il fallait bien je me
repose 40 ans donc on a choisi une
sécurité puis au dernier brest leader
pratiquement depuis le début du tour la
surprise est pourtant venu dans la
dernière étape qu'à demandons au départ
de cannes les bretons posséder 47 milles
d'avancé sur leur second dunkerque à
cause d'un orage accompagné de vents
tourbillonnants les brestois a accusé
sur ce parcours près de deux heures de
retard sur le bateau nordiste
à l'arrivée à montaut il perdait ainsi
sur le fil le deuxième tour de france à
la voile et surtout observer le plan
d'eau et puis voilà ici fait pas grand
chose pourquoi passer à côté battre à
annonay comme hier on a toujours observé
de nouveaux pions se balader sous les
nuages et les trois cas de bateaux de
tête c'est comme ça que vous marchez 25
bateaux partis de dunkerque y arriver
sans casse en montant après cinq
semaines de course le long des côtes
françaises c'est à mettre à l'actif de
cette épreuve autre acquis non
négligeable de ce deuxième tour de
france à la voile toutes les heures de
navigation accompli par plus de 350
jeunes et dans des conditions parfois
difficiles
demande en question par le magazine de
jean pierre elkabbach et d'un griot nous
rentrerons délirant régaler qui a
réalisé un film au large de l'île
maurice sur les lieux mêmes où fut
découverte l'épave du bateau de paul et
virginie demain qui sera intense sur
antenne 2 dans lequel vous pourrez
également suivre un hommage alain colas
en bref je vous rappellerai simplement
une nouvelle halle aux sports en escrime
à melbourne aux championnats du monde
une médaille d'argent pour le français
pascal joly je ferai une surprise suivi
d'une déception et la cinquième place de
didier flamand champion du monde l'année
dernière la météo demain
les vents de nord à nord ouest faible à
modéré dans l'intérieur seront nous
deviendrons assez fort à la fois près de
la manche ainsi que sur le languedoc et
la provence les températures resteront
l'agrément match jeunes entre 17 et 18
degrés dans le nord et 23 à 24 degrés
dans le midi le ciel sera souvent très
nuageux avec un passage pluvieux qui n'y
gagneront calé région méditerranée n'est
plus qu'à vous dire que c'est bernard
pradines que vous retrouverez en fin de
programme pour les dernières
informations et vous invitez toutefois à
terminer ce journal en feuilletant un
album des photos originales vous avez
sans doute souvent remarqué l'été ces
hordes de touristes bardet d'appareils
photos toujours en mitraillant tout ce
qui se trouve à l'emporter en disant
toujours on est content de regarder le
pays qu'ils ont visité une fois rentrés
chez eux
et bien comme dans l'histoire de
l'arroseur arrosé notre photographe éric
pelletier s'est amusé lui a photographié
les photographes
man spears dans glee choqué a kiss et
abla espagnol et palma italia manantsoa
en japonais se dit le plus souvent
parfums hors taxes
mais oui rnd une dame l'a 19 jan aps le
masne paris au mois d'août appartient
qui veut bien le prendre en photo ap
d'ailleurs tout même vous me dit la main
sur le sacré coeur bien une veine id
penven nouveautés ville comme wayne wang
haiwen corde ou à vent
bienvenue donc d'ailleurs tour eiffel is
money le reste les histoires sont par
ailleurs